let's talk about how stupid all that
cultural stuff is getting we got this
story from cnn.com
patton oswalt defends his longtime
friendship with dave chappelle no he
didn't he apologized
patton oswalt was doing a show dave
chappelle was doing a bigger show after
patton oswalt's show ended dave was like
yo come in do a set we got a big arena
and so pat oswalt did and you know he
was probably thinking pan oswalt is he's
famous
but is he dave chappelle
no
so imagine you're like yeah you're in a
band and people have heard of you and
you maybe make six figures it's all
right you you're an opening act and then
all of a sudden like metallica at an
arena is like why don't you come in and
do a do a do a set you're gonna be like
dude an arena and you're gonna go super
excited but oh no oh no people are mad
at you now so patton oswalt posts this
photo where he's like look at me i'm
with my friend dave i've known him for
so long i'm so happy to be here and he
got attacked for it people started
saying that uh you know he was hurting
the lgbtq community and things like that
that he doesn't understand the damage
and the pain so he takes this other
photo on instagram where he's like he's
got like a yellow notepad and he's
writing down something looking pensive
in front of the mirror and he's just
like if i had known the hurt that i
would have caused
and he's like to think i would tell
other people they need to to learn oh
you know what grow a spine dude you took
a picture with your friend that's it
dave chappelle's a funny guy grow up
it's like he was punished and told by a
teacher write an essay why you're sorry
for having a friend for decades i mean
are you kidding me there's also a lot of
fake news spreading around this there
was a caption that dave chappelle
stopped to help this elderly lesbian
after her suburban broke down uh that
was fake news didn't happen
going around with that photo just a meme
out there uh but but it tells you what
kind of times we're living in where a
person who was friends with someone for
for decades is is apologizing for taking
a photo with them
you know what was funny is people
started going back into pat and oswalt's
uh old stand-up routine
and they found that patton had made very
like
i would say it goes beyond just being
transgressive it was almost like
mean-spirited jokes about transgender
people like far worse than anything that
chappelle had ever done this was just a
few years ago it's probably from 2014 or
something people started posting that on
twitter like oh pat no you're so
embarrassed of you know dave chappelle
and you were doing this but i think
that's part of the rhetorical move you
have to make when you're in these
circles and that a few years ago if you
wanted to be like
a bully you would be making like
anti-transgender jokes or making
anti-gay jokes or blah blah now if you
want to be a bully you got to be woke
right you got to be woke about it you
can still be like really hateful and
like spiteful towards people and you can
still basically be that bully but you're
going to have to do it in a different
direction i think that's what patent
while he's orienting himself to where he
feels like his hollywood malou is now
which is that you know dave chappelle is
one of the most popular entertainers in
america but he may not be that popular
among a certain subset of cultural
liberals in hollywood right the the one
segment of people in the news media and
entertainment who actually did take a
great deal of offense towards his his
comedy routines which i think honestly
if you polled most transgender people in
america i think most of them probably
wouldn't even have been offended because
most of them most of them were in good
taste and if you look at his routines he
makes fun of everybody and most of those
people don't get offended at it because
they understand the purpose and role of
comedy and levity in society right
yeah well that all seems to be going
away i guess except for the fact you
know netflix keeps signing more and more
deals with dave chappelle so let me just
say this
dave chappelle is being signed to
netflix because netflix has the data
netflix looks at who's watching dave
chappelle and they're like wow everybody
loves this guy let's give him more money
you see netflix doesn't make money off
of advertisements they make money off of
memberships if they book dave chappelle
to do a headline you know major special
on netflix and they give him how much
how much are they paying him it's like
tens of millions of dollars a lot an
employee leaked the information to the
general public it wasn't like for 25
million
you know what look i know dave's the
best of the best
and
it takes a lot of work to do these
specials but that much money for that
much work it's just like wow when you're
good you're good right but netflix is
thinking we are going to gain more
paying subscribers by booking the sky
then we will lose over any outrage
we've known this
the the the leftist outrage the the foe
complaints it's like 30 people on
twitter who won't stop talking and they
convince people like patent oswald he
gets convinced oh everyone's mad at me
because he got like 30 people constantly
spamming him over and over and over
again reminds me of that family guy joke
where the guy's like we got seven phone
calls left last night which means 70
billion people are upset that's what it
is
so dave chappelle is going to keep
getting booked we're going to keep
laughing but
you guys i don't know if you guys saw
his last special
they're getting to him
oh yeah yeah he was defensive he he
spends a lot of i would say the past few
specials he spends a portion of the time
sort of defending himself against claims
being made against him right which is
not really where you want to be as a
comedian
you want to focus on the jokes on the
entertainment it does sound like you
know if i was him i maybe i'd avoid some
of those jokes in the next special focus
on some different topics or just take
some time off but you know he's in that
space now and i think it's just it is
again that small
minority of persistent angry people can
do this to you if you're in certain
social spaces even if the vast majority
of america i think understands that dave
chappelle's always been a little bit
risque he's always been a little bit
edgy um but he's there to make you laugh
he doesn't actually hate anybody he
doesn't try to make anyone hate anybody
uh but that's where a lot of these
spaces are now and that's why someone
like patton oswalt feels like he has to
apologize for a friendship with one of
the most probably one of the most
popular entertainers in the entire
country but they made to dave chappelle
get serious and that's what really kind
of affected everything and and you bring
up a small amount of people we have to
understand that the small amount of
people have a lot of institutional power
especially when it comes to the
corporate media literally promoting a
netflix protest saying that speaking
about it but but when you talk about
something and say there's going to be a
big protest here there's going to be a
protest here you're bringing attention
to it just to clarify though when we're
talking about a small amount of people
we're talking about you know
john you know at john96321 on twitter
it's these random profiles where they
have no followers they're not
necessarily bots i don't think they're
bots they could be sock puppets but
someone like pat and oswald you look at
his tweet about this and he's just
inundated with like you you can really
only see maybe like 30 to 50 tweets or
whatever like unless you really want to
scroll through everything and they're
like do better i can't believe you would
do this dave's hurting us and you're
like that's probably
30 to 50 people out of the millions of
people who follow patent oswald how many
are logging onto twitter
clicking his post and then complaining
point zero zero one percent point zero
zero zero one percent but these people
see these things and they assume that
wow everybody's mad i better talk about
something making it worse dave chappelle
gets dragged into it he got serious and
there was a there's a cnn article
generated about this right there was
actually a cbc journalist a canadian
broadcast corporation journalist who
just resigned from her post
and she just wrote a subtech piece about
why and one of the complaints that she
had was that you know you guys kept
running these articles about how people
find dave chappelle offensive why didn't
we ever go to the vast majority of
people who just like him and ask them
what they think right like
the media may be a small number of
people but it is a powerful institution
and they you know they're going to be
writing articles about you you know that
someone's going to be taking issue with
it even if it's a few dozen people at
netflix it's going to be portrayed as a
massive staff revolt you know that is a
headache in and of itself imagine
the narrative being that netflix knows
their audience doesn't like dave
chappelle that people are greatly
offended and don't watch it and they
booked him anyway that's the stupidest
thing i've ever heard no they're booking
him because he's bringing in members
he's bringing in money now for me i
don't have a netflix account ever since
they did that thing with the cuties yeah
i was like whoa
did they like double down on it sure
it's bad enough netflix has that show
about uh
i don't even want to talk about this
show yeah a bunch of mainstream
celebrities talking about kids in adult
situations and that is putting it very
lightly
i'm surprised they have that show in the
first place i don't know anybody who
watches to be completely honest uh and
like
for the most part you know we're not
like a staunch conservative suit-wearing
tp-usa kind of kind of place around here
you know we have like skaters
skateboarders rollerbladers punk rock
music
relative contrarians to a certain degree
and people aren't just being like oh
turn on you know big mouth on netflix
that's a show i like people are like
that's nasty like i don't know what they
were thinking with that show it's just
whatever but hey look
i'm not interested in watching a show
like that or watching cuties and if
they're if they want to keep doubling
down on that stuff i'm not going to be
interested in being a member or
subscribing to that to a platform like
that you know what i mean
and and i think that raises a lot more
controversy especially with the cuties a
lot of people not signing up then
compared to dave chappelle that's only
from my perspective i could be wrong but
but again
they continue to work with dave
chappelle that's a big sign that
obviously the general public a large
vast amount of people
like his comedy they want to hear edgy
stuff they want to hear stuff that
lightens the situation and when you're
able to joke about issues that the
establishment doesn't want you to talk
about if you're able to joke around
serious issues you're able to of course
make people relate to them better you're
able to of course get rid of a lot of
the stigma a lot of the hate a lot of
the negative energy around it i would
say comedians are absolutely crucial
towards bettering society bettering our
discourse and this is an effort to as we
were talking about earlier to destroy
that conversation and to create more
eco-changes i feel like almost the way
that comedy is getting around this a
little bit is um
a lot of these networks are bringing in
either foreign or i think
maybe more cultural you know niche
cultural subjects and actors and
producers to produce a lot of the same
stuff like
if you watch some of the foreign
programming on netflix i think you'll
find much kind of racier jokes or much
uh edgier more risque material than i
think what you might see in a dave
chappelle stand up and i think part of
that is that you're kind of getting out
right like if it's like if it's a
foreign produced if it happens to be
international comedy or international
cultures uh maybe these same subcultures
of americans in these companies and
institutions that media give it a little
bit more of a pass right um which is
kind of funny like if you have to watch
like a korean drama to be able to like
see funny comedy about topics that
people want to be transgressive about
but uh it almost feels like you have to
do that sometimes there's a video on
youtube oh yeah that we bring up every
so often it is from august 9 2010 it is
from the onion and it is titled overcome
stress by visualizing it as a greedy
hook-nosed race of creatures
oh my it's the onion
and i can't even tell you what the jokes
are about because
yeah i mean
i'm wondering if we can because it's on
youtube itself
but it's a woman and she's like when you
have money troubles visualize a greedy
hook-nosed race of creatures and it's
very obviously like a demeaning picture
like a very disgusting picture of a
stereo like i don't even i don't i don't
even want to i don't want to get into it
i don't get it the point is i think
people understand the joke the onions
making here terrible and this has got
1.5 million views youtube still has it
up this is what comedy was just 10 years
ago
for these networks now comedies turned
into like what's south park did the joke
with jimmy he's like hey what's the deal
with mexican food it's excellent cuisine
and i love it
like it's not even a joke
yeah yeah i mean actually it is kind of
funny when you're making fun of it well
one one show i really like is called
rami and i don't know if you guys have
seen rami um but basically it's about a
it stars an egyptian american who's also
the the writer and show runner and you
know he lives in new jersey and he has
an egyptian american family trying to
grow up in the states with kind of these
cultural clashes and like he has an
uncle who's like very anti-semitic and
like constantly making jew jokes but he
like he still loves them even though he
kind of tells them that it's like not
right to do that but like yeah that's
the cultural context you have to go to
to discuss something like that because
like it's not openly
like if the character was like white
american or like christian or something
like they wouldn't be allowed to have an
uncle who does that and like talk about
it and like actually normalize it and
let people like talk around their
differences because you have to actually
cast a character like that and have a
showrunner like that to be actually able
to approach these issues now because
there's so much sensitivity in talking
about cultural differences right if you
watch an older some of those older shows
like good times or the jeffersons
from the 60s and 70s they openly talked
about like racial stereotypes of like
whites and blacks between each other
that's how they broke down a lot of the
difference now it's just like you just
have to say the party line like you
break these things down by just beating
things into people's heads rather than
actually letting them be open about
their prejudices and talking them
through right i mean you look at uh
pat and oswald as a person and you look
at dave chappelle as a person and i'm
just like i kind of know who i'd rather
watch if i was given an opportunity the
you know the whiny crybaby who's like
i'm so sorry for the paint or dave
chappelle who doubles down granted he
got a little bit defensive on his last
special for sure but absolutely it was
like i don't care you know what i mean
i'm gonna say what i want and i'm like
yeah that's that's more appealing to me
it's more honest well that's why they're
trying to get rid of him anyone speaking
truth is is deemed as a heretic in this
new kind of cult of woke and he's the
one willing to speak the larger truths
that a lot of people are thinking but
too afraid to say and we're pretty far
away from the days of george carlin
richard pryor and bill hicks but man did
those individuals
make comedy great make the first
amendment something that a lot of people
stood behind and these larger ideas that
they represented that they were able the
effect that they were able to have on
people was so important and i don't
think enough people attribute them to
the larger successes that we have as a
country as a nation as a culture uh
because of these individuals that stood
on their principles and in some
instances we're even arrested for it so
shout out to those individuals if you
haven't heard of them if you're someone
who never heard of these names look them
up look up their old videos and be
prepared to be astonished at the larger
truth bombs that they were dropping on
people that absolutely have awakened
humanity you have a list of names uh i
just uh listed uh three of them i could
probably think of some more what are
your favorite comedians i mean eddie
murphy too eddie murphy was also able to
go to places that a lot of people saw is
extremely controversial he doubled down
tripled down on it um especially when it
came to bill cosby um eddie murphy
called out bill cosby way before anybody
else uh in a very very important way who
who's your guys's favorite linda um my
so my favorite comedians are not really
all that transgressive i never really
got into george carlin um but i feel
like every comedian has some form of
history of offensive jokes that they now
are walking back and i've always felt
that a lot of these comedians have made
a point of pulling up the ladder behind
them which i really hate to see i would
like to see some of them with some form
of character which is why i really liked
dave chappelle and i do hope this is not
getting to him or or or all these
comedians just be like shut up i don't
care i'm going to make jokes yep well
yes
1990s
uh congress brought a series of people
to testify and grill them some of them
were the heads of labels for uh
musicians and artists recording artists
others were heads of like video game
firms like sega of america and so on and
so forth
and universally what they would say is
like this is our freedom of expression
we don't think that this is going to
promote real world violence or real
world misogyny real world et cetera et
cetera
you know this is a place where people go
to escape so on and so forth
now those very same firms when they're
grilled by congress when they're grown
by the media typically they they concede
something right typically they back down
or they try to appease the the
opposition i think the culture of their
response has changed a lot in the face
of a lot of these protests and i'm not
sure what the difference is between now
and the 1990s but you'll see
you know tipper gore uh bob dole joe
lieberman bill clinton these people all
going after these companies and the
company's just responding that it's our
right to to be able to speak freely and
um you know it's entertainment it's not
real it's not real life right yeah
people in the comment section are
bringing up andrew dice clay uh lenny
bruce yes uh uh norm mcdonald and arm
also of course uh bob saget and uh bob
yeah he right there i mean if there's if
there's something that's going to raise
a couple hairs on your head it's
definitely the comedy of uh bob saget so
there's been a number of individuals and
and i think the reason why we go to
comedians is because they're able to
talk about these issues that so many
people are afraid to talk about and
there's not only a layer of kind of
controversy people are also talking
about patrice o'neill he was also really
just an amazing comedian mel brooks as
well but but they're able to to
you know hash things out through a way
that is bringing people together instead
of dividing them and if you want to push
the divide and conquer agenda
effectively you have to get rid of
comedy you have to get rid of satire
because it's one of the most effective
weapons against the establishment
against the ruling elite against the
very powerful because if you mock them
you take away all of their power and all
of their influence and we need more
mockery than ever thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time